هذا موجز الاخبار من قناه الجزيره قال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
باتريدر في تصريح حصلت عليه الجزيره ان
البنتاجون رصد تقارير عن منطاد يعبر اجواء
امريكا اللاتينيه واضاف رايدر ان تقييم هو
انه منطاد استطلاع صيني اخر
الغى وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه سفره الى
بيجين على خلفيه دخول منطاد تجسس الصيني
الاجواء الامريكيه
بحسبه ما ذكرته الخارجيه الامريكيه وقال
بلينكل انه اوضح لعضو مجلس الدوله الصيني
ان دخول المنطاد الى الاراضي الامريكيه هو
انتهاك للسياده
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الصينيه ان المنطقه
الصيني الذي رصدته الولايه المتحده مدني
يستخدمه لاغراض البحث خصوصا للرصد الجوي
واضافت الوزاره ان المنتظم انحرف بعيدا عن
مساره المخطط له
اعلن وزير العدل الامريكي امريكا انه اجاز
اول عمليه نقل لاصول مصادره من احد رجال
النخبه الروسيه الى وزاره الخارجيه
لاستخدامها في دعم اوكرانيا جاء تصريحات
جيرلاند خلال استقباله المدعي العام
الاوكراني في واشنطن
من جهته قال المدعي العام الاوكراني ان
الاصول الروسيه التي سيتم نقلها ستستخدم
لصالح جهود اعاده الاعمار
تعهد الاتحاد الاوروبي في ختام قمه
الاتحاد واوكرانيا امس بدعم مساعي
اوكرانيا للانضمام اليها وقال الاتحاد في
بيان انه سيتخذ مزيدا من الخطوات بمجرد
تلبيه جميع الشروط المحدده من قبل
للانضمام
من جهته قال الرئيس الاوكراني
هدف بلاده واضح وهو بدء المفاوضات بشان
عضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
الاتحاد العامه التونسي للشغل لاجراءات
الرئيس قيس سعيد واعتبرها محاوله للتغطيه
على فشل الانتخابات واعلن الاتحاد انه اقر
عددا من التحركات اعتبارا من هذا الاسبوع
وانه سيعلن عنها لاحقا ودعم النقابيين
لتوحيد الصفوف
وطلب الرئيس التونسي قيس السعيد بتطهير
البلاد ومحاسبه كل من عبث بمقدراتها
وبتطبيق القانون على الجميع واضاف ان
الطرقات ليست ملكا خاصا لتغلق في اشاره
لاضراب نقابه الطرقات السياره التابعه
للاتحاد العام للشغله
اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حاره
المقايض في مخيم عقبه جبر في مدينه اريحا
بالضفه الغربيه وافاد شهود عيان بان قوته
الاحتلال اقتحمت وحاصرت منزلا حيث دارت
اشتباكات مسلحه في محيط المنزل
ختام هذا الموجز الى اللقاء